[Music]
let's get started
1681 with black
all right d4
let's see what we can do let's go knight
f6
i'm feeling adventurous
i'm in a celebratory mood so
let's play another budapest gambit shall
we
now we played this a little earlier and
our opponent didn't take on e5 let's
hope that they do here
this is an opening that's not talked
about very often anymore pretty
underrated actually i think if
and as i've said when you're 1700 i
would already recommend having
your main opening
and then
a sideline that's not like flat out bad
but could be dubious but one that you
know pretty well that you can throw out
for fun and again
you can see that people in this writing
range just aren't confident facing
these second tier openings which can
actually be a really good thing d5 is
not a great move it gives black
it gives us all that we want how should
this be
how should we meet this well
we should make a natural developing move
here which also
happens to exploit one of the drawbacks
of d5 which is that it it gives up the
c5 square we have a really nice nook
on c5 that was we could stick the bishop
in
and then we could follow up with d6 a
common
common sequence and then later
we could think about playing c7 c6 in
order to
cut into white's uh white's center
okay so let's start by playing
d6 just to anchor the bishop and
obviously open up the other bishop this
is equal i mean white is not worse here
but
he's not causing us any opening problems
that's for sure and bishop g5 here would
be a very common tactical blunder
due to bishop takes f2 check of course
knight a4 is not that annoying we could
play bishop before check okay e4
this already
this already is quite dubious i think
because it it weakens a couple of things
it weakens the d4 square which can be an
outpost
you know if we can ever get our knight
there
it also opens up
that fully opens up the diagonal
and our bishop is now pressuring f2 and
white can no longer play e3
uh to
sort of
decrease the pressure and so what move
comes to mind what moves should at least
be considered
uh even if it looks very uh
very superficial but in fact it's quite
hard to meet knight g4 i think we should
play it
ig-4 looks excellent here
the only way to defend this pawn is
knight h3 but if we can get white to
play knight h3 that's already a good
sign in the moment in such d4 openings
that the knight
uh leaves f6 you should immediately
start thinking about pushing that f bomb
forward to f5 and trying to open up
the f file but before we do that the
ideal scenario in which to open up the
fl would be if there would be a rook on
f8 right if there's a rook on f8 we
could increase the pressure on f2
a lot of you want to play queen h4 here
i don't love quinn h4 because of g3
so we should make the com developing
move castles
i think our opponent's gonna go bishop
e2
and then we can still play f5 at least
we can consider it
uh because that pawn will defend the
knight
bishop p2 there is also queen h4
which is very very strong in that
position since g3 is no longer possible
f3 is also
a move that we could
possibly expect
oh queen f6 is pretty easy to defend
against white can play queen c2 for
instance
thank you dylan render for the raid
queen f3
our opponent walking straight into f5
right and that's
maybe white thinks that he's stopping f5
but
obviously
it's not you can play it anyway and this
is even stronger this could be a a very
quick game if white is not careful
if white is not very careful
so what are we threatening precisely
we're threatening f takes c4 and knight
takes f2
we've got three attackers
on the f2 pawn
bishop e3
ooh
okay wait a minute
let me think here
it already feels like we have a win in
this position but i i'm still looking
for one
there's so many tactics i mean look at
how our pieces are all converging on
the queen side but we have to patiently
uh consider our options and actually
find something
hmm
it's amazing
it looks like there's so many different
things here but
got many ways to get a better position
not seeing a forced win just yet
so the first
option would be to play f takes e4 and
then after queen takes c4 the move
bishop f5 comes to mind which looks like
it traps the queen the queen can drop
back to
f3 and i don't see a particularly
effective discover check there now the
simplest option in that position would
be just to play knight takes e3 and
settle for a a very big advantage just
due to the fact that we have you know a
very big initiative we have a positional
advantage and a tactical advantage
that's very possible now we should
consider other moves bishop takes c3 and
then f takes e4
runs into the same issue after bishop f5
queen f3
i just don't
see a an effective discovery
it's possible that we should just play
knight take c3 after c4
and then we should make a developing
move such as knight a6 trying to get to
b4 sometimes that is
the way to solve these kinds of
positions let's see
give me another 15 seconds to think
yeah i'm not seeing anything
quite as appetizing as i would like so
let's take on e4 maybe our opponent gets
scared and plays queen g3
yeah i think we should just go for the
two bishops and we'll check with an
engine afterward
okay we're going for the two bishops
and a big advantage just positionally
now you could take on h3 and try to ruin
white structure but that's not worth it
giving up your light squared bishop in a
position like this
would hurt quite a bit because then
white would go bishop d3 and
cause problems
along the diagonals so queen h4 blunders
the queen
we should start with bishop f5
that's a frequent
queen f3 forced only square for the
queen
now a lot of people struggle
in this kind of situation where
everybody
watching this can sense that we are much
better it looks like something should
announce itself and yet nothing does
so in such situations you can't just
like panic and
sort of tilt your way into some
bad move
sometimes the solution is just to make a
calm developing move
or just to improve your position in some
way so for instance knight a6 is
possible
in that case the white can go a3 and
prevent knight b4
so we could also go knight d7
and just develop the knight and connect
the rooks right it's
the whole thing about not every move
having to
uh
cure covet or whatever
so we're just gonna make a very zen
developing move knight d7
and what often tends to happen if you
play such moves they're quite annoying
for the opponent
and often blunders happen shortly after
these kinds of moves you almost get
rewarded for
uh for being very patient and and making
one of these
just general improving moves thank you
france rando
yeah queen h4 is on the cards as well
but
right now it it runs into g3 for
instance so or queen g3
so we shouldn't rush that move
maybe queen h4 was better though queen
h4 check i i honestly forgot
that after queen g3 it's all the
champagne castle's queen side
there's the blunder
something announced itself
what is it
it's not a free queen but it's it's an
exchange an exchange in this position is
decisive
we win an exchange in the middle game
that's great
so our opponent rushed
their development and boom bishop c2 we
win the exchange
and that should give us enough material
to
win the game pretty comfortably
okay
so we need to be careful about a couple
of things here
one thing is we need to be careful about
this maneuver knight 2596 could be a
little bit nasty if we're not
properly
prepared for it now probably the
simplest approach here would be to aim
for a queen trade
and try to do it down the f file so
let's go queen f6 to get this queen into
the game
and then we've got several ideas queen
g6 and queen f2
both come to mind
you know queen trade makes sense here
given that we're up in exchange and it
would
facilitate our
uh our oh my god what am i saying sorry
i almost played it i forgot that white
didn't play knight g5 jesus
i'm telling you it's the champagne
i in my mind white had already played
knight g5
that was disaster very narrowly averted
i was just testing everybody
okay so instead of this what we're gonna
do is go e4
and open up the e5 square for the knight
and if knight takes e4 then i don't
think the splendor's a queen queen takes
b2
oh my goodness
it's been a long day
that would have been
hilarious i don't think i would have
been able to come back from that that's
literally a full queen
that's a full queen for nothing
you passed you definitely passed
guess the elo i mean levy would probably
think this is like
wow this guy's playing pretty decently
oh never mind 1300
okay so here
we can already play queen f2 although
bishop takes h7
probably shouldn't be allowed
although you know it's not dangerous in
this position i think we can play knight
takes c4 and start collecting stuff i
think we can play knight takes c4 and
start collecting stuff
the reason i say bishop takes h7 is not
dangerous is because
after king h8
if white then plays queen h4 right
trying to set up a discover check
and possibly a mate against the king
we simply have queen h6 that's probably
what's gonna happen we have queen h6
intercepting the queen
and it's important to realize that when
you're up material you can't avoid
calculation you you're still gonna have
to sometimes
you know
accept a little bit of not danger even
but let's take on e3 first except a
little bit of
counter play and refute it and that's a
totally normal process of
uh that happens it doesn't mean you did
something wrong
queen h6 ends the game immediately
basically because
white is no longer any attack and
white's hole position collapses
all it took is one move
knight h7 instead of bishop takes h7
there was like knight takes b2 check
i'll show that after the game
only hikari karo can come back from that
now that might be true
oh i i didn't talk much about e4
which is a a pretty powerful move i
think
okay queen g3 good move for your
opponent
now we have many ways of winning this
this kind of position
um
it depends on sort of the approach that
that you want to take
one of the better approaches is well
what i'm seeing is that rook aea
would be a check were it not for
the knight that's sort of sitting on e3
so we can drop the knight back to f5
offering a trade and trying to get the
rook to f2
that's one option
but let's go rook 88 i mean let's just
get the rook into the game this is the
most flexible and it's also the most
harmonious you know it's the most
uh
you know sort of representative of the
kind of technique that i advocate for
which is to get all your pieces into the
game and be methodical and all that
stuff
now i think knight f5 is great
because we're changing
the knight for the rook
in addition to knight f5
you also have the cute move knight f1
same idea trying to get rookie 3
check-in
knight f1 is
probably even better
let's go knight f1
yeah we'll we'll go knight f1
and then the other rook could also swoop
into f2 so there might be some sort of a
mating attack
pretty shortly
yeah that rook is
has seen better days
yeah rookie three rook f2 our king is
safe we should keep an eye on
knight f7
we should keep an eye on the back rank
if both of the rooks leave the eighth
rank
but
i mean it's it's winning
check
i really hope he goes king c4 because
we're going to have a king hun then
good defense by our opponent i have to
say let me think for a second
okay check
there is a crazy line where white's king
and he's going for it let's give another
check king a4 and somehow
white's king is
not safe but
not checkable for the time being and
notice that i mentioned the eighth rank
that was an important comment because
queen c8
is a very very serious threat that's
actually a mate threat
so what we should do is make another
patient defensive move
one of the hardest things to do is to
make defensive moves while you're
attacking and yet that's a necessary
very very necessary thing to do
so we just need to move
a rook
either to e8 or to f8
i'm thinking rook e8 just to keep the
stroke on
duty of protecting f7
i have to say our opponent played this
this stretch extremely well
and made it difficult for us to convert
but i i think we're going to be
successful
now we're one move away from setting up
unstoppable threats for instance queen
f6 is a very good move
why because it threatens rook f4 like
i'm see
when i look at this position i'm seeing
a couple of things straight away i'm
seeing
that the queen and the king are on the
same rank so rook out setting up rook f4
could be a very good idea i'm seeing
also that
involving our queen in the king hunt
could be good so combining those two
observations yields the move queen f6
looks like a pretty mundane move but
it's actually very strong as it
threatens rook f4 and potentially queen
d4
the other idea i'm saying is to go a6 b5
using our pawns the further the king the
closer the king is toward your camp
the higher the probability that you can
actually use your pawns and
um
you know contribute to the king hut by
driving the king further upward
now rookie four
doesn't work rookie that square is
defended by a million pieces
what if white goes rookie won yeah
rookie one would be a very high level
move we would meet that with the rook f8
i would be impressed if white finds
rookie one
a deflection sacrifice we cannot take it
because of backrank mate but we would go
rook ef-8
and that also happens to threaten a
fork with a rook f4 so it sort of kills
two birds with one stone
our opponent will probably lose on time
though
yeah b5 another one of those typical
moves that you should always consider
just throwing your pawns at the king to
open up more files and diagonals and all
that stuff
okay our opponent's gonna lose on time
yeah the position is
losing
definitely losing at this point okay
so
yeah highly anticlimactic sorry about
that
yeah so already e4 is a mistake i think
and
you know it's a mistake because it opens
up this diagonal and now white has a
hard time putting anything between the
bishop and the pawn so we go knight g4
knight h3 castles
now f3 could have been met with the
positional move knight e3
essentially forcing white to give up the
bishop
and this is a terrible situation right
because the dark squared bishop is
unopposed
it's controlling both of these diagonals
i mean it's controlling look at how many
crucial squares it's controlling
and this is a terrible terrible position
for white just terrible
yeah one e4 is a mistake so i think our
opponent
played queen f3 probably white should
play bishop e2 here
and then meet f5 with castles
more or less getting a playable position
this is not pleasant but it's something
so bishop e3
we'll check after the game fe queen e4
so we decided to go for a very
positional approach knight d7
and now bishop c2 wins the exchange
i want to fast forward because i was
explaining these moves pretty clearly
let's move e4
very
important concept to push a pawn your
own pawn
because you can't you're not allowed to
push your opponent's pawns and open up a
square for the knight like that
concept itself is
quite common positionally and i've even
shown a game before on stream
where one of my favorite illustrations
of this exact concept which occurs quite
frequently in the benoni so in this
position black plays h6
and
white does something kind of cool here
so i think most people
would probably be inclined to drop the
bishop back to h4 right basically
i mean bishop f6 looks very
anti-position like why would you give up
your dark script bishop and give black a
what looks like a very nice dark square
bishop
but he takes on f6 and he does it
because of the follow-up what does white
do in this position
so
f5 is premature
why is it premature because it gives up
this
monster
square on e5 black it parked the bishop
i mean look how nice this bishop is and
then black could play queen g5 but the
idea is correct it's just that first you
go e5
okay de5
but not f5 just yet if you go f5 here
then black will play e4 and open up the
bishop sacrificing back the pawn
so first he uses tactics and plays
knight g to e4 there's that idea opening
up the square formerly occupied by the
pawn
he takes f4 doesn't work knight takes f6
and notice that white punishes black for
the lack of queen side development
all of a sudden it comes back to bite
him
after bishop g75 that's it the bishop is
totally entombed
white is winning this knight is a
monster white's got
you know easy kingside pressure
why that knight well the other night's
defending d5 he just didn't want to give
up the d5 pawn
and white wins very easily
fgfg rook f6 is a nice move
doubling rooks
rook takes g6 threatening a fork
and the attack is
completely and utterly overwhelming
black finally gets the night out but by
that point it's too late white is
checkmating
him is there an alternative no i mean
this is the best move that's why i'm
showing this game
e5 opening up the square
uh pushing the pawn in front sacrificing
and opening up the score for the night i
think this is this example is a
not the only illustration
by any means but a good one
black did not play like a 1700 that's
completely untrue it's just that he made
an earlier mistake there was nothing
black could have done after he played e5
and it's easy to look at a game like
that and say the opposing side played
terribly but that's the effect that
these good ideas have
so a very similar concept you play e4 in
order to open up the square for then
when you're up material you should be a
little bit more willing to sacrifice
something like a pawn
now 94 there's queen takes p2 which is
crushing
there should be 495 and this knight is a
monster it's in the center it's
attacking c4 we took c4
yeah originally i wanted to play queen
f2 here
but after bishop h7 king h8 queen h3
there's very nasty situation white
threatens to move the bishop back
so we decided on knight c4
and after queen h6
white has virtually no attack we get the
rook into the game
we block white's rokin
same concept you like clear up a square
by moving a piece out of the way
and okay well i lost on time but
we've got tons of threads here i think
it's safe to say black is winning
let's check one thing with the engine
which is that
just very curious to see
what the best move was
after bishop e3 like what is it that we
missed
fb4 is correct we need four
okay so the best move was bishop e3
fv3 and now
knight a6
wow oh i see the point i i i the point
is that white can't defend the e3 pawn
that's the problem
for instance if i castles
we go knight c5
and wherever the queen was we take on e3
with totally devastating effect i mean
not only is the exchange lost but if
white goes queen b1
then we can also
like i mean
bishop h3 gh and queen g5 just
unstoppable discovered check
that's a nice oops sorry that's a nice
concept
that's a very nice concept
yeah so we took with a knight which is
the second best move and now still
knight a6 so i initially suggested this
i mean the way we played was not bad
notice that it's it's still -3 it's it's
like it's still
it's still good but
but uh bishop e3 knight a6 very nice
idea
using the knight
to
to attack e3 should shouldn't have given
away this night
but yeah knight a6 you would think of if
you're a kings indian player like this
is a typical
knight a65 and this is where the
frankfurt airport analogy comes in if
you're saying to yourself i would never
thought of that well that's
it shouldn't be the case because it's
the key to this move isn't knight a6
right the key is to notice that you want
to get the knight to c5 and then the way
to get it there matters a lot well it
does matter you can't go knight d70
blunder the knight so you don't go 97
because it's cool you go knight a6
because it's the only way to get it
there
a6 is frankfurt airport you're going to
rome on c5 and you should always reverse
engineer
night maneuvers like where do you want
it
and then how you get it there is just a
matter of where
you know which airports are accessible
so that's about it that was a good game
and with that i'm going to and i'm
exhausted
yeah so thank you everybody once again
for the awesome support uh and the
great community that we've built on
youtube and twitch over the years
which will continue to build so thanks
to everybody once again
it's been real
i'll see you guys later have a great
night everybody and thanks again bye
cheers
[Music]